what I wanted to talk about was a few of
my experiences with King upon n games
these and games are in particularly ah
they're so marvelously tricky and this
of course is not a king of pawning game
but it has a great story to it so I have
to share it with yourselves okay so what
this position this position has been
reached very recently in the tournament
in vikon's a holland and i was the
commentator the online commentator doing
broadcasts for the event and Evon chuck
had been in deep trouble against yo
Brava for the longest time but as white
he had really fought himself out of his
difficulties and got himself into this
crazy position
Evon Chuck advanced the pong and I had
been spending some of my time looking at
what would have happened if the pawn had
been captured the pawn goes down the
board and black gets his King behind
upon his rook behind upon but definitely
there is at least a draw here for white
because white will always be able to
advance his King to d7 and would force
black to to make a check from behind so
that line of play would not be winning
for black another interesting line of
play would be this one takes takes rook
f5 I look out for pardon me attacking
upon on F
f-five and rook here so in this case you
could get a situation where for example
after King here King to d6 pawn to b4 it
starts getting really wild like you know
who's going to win and how would it go
for example pawn here there was a funny
trick rook takes rook takes pawn takes
pawn here hold on no this isn't let's
say yeah pawn here and takes eggs yeah
gotta make a queen and this check ooh
yeah so there was tricks like this and I
had been calculating these tricks when
suddenly and very surprisingly you Vova
offered to go into a King and pawn
endgame now again black had been better
for a very very long time and it looked
like a very strange decision to go into
a King and pawn in game when you go into
a king of pawn game that's one one of
those things you have to be absolutely
sure you're burning your bridges either
you're lost with run or draw and you've
got to take precise play and the first
thing that went through my mind is was
yeah the first thing that went through
my mind was like okay why on earth could
this be winning four before black right
so I was thinking okay so king c6 and
how is black going to win this or what
would the result be so I was trying to
analyze this position at the same time
there were other games and I was
flipping back and forth and suddenly
in the odd and the studio was even
shocked
Yvonne Jacques white Yvonne Jacques had
just played the move rook takes a four
and his opponent resigned whoa why did
he resign why didn't you just take the
rock and then and then see what the
opponent was going to do and I hadn't
figured out how black was going to win
uh-uh uh-uh how white was going to win
pardon me and I said well welcome Yvonne
Vasiliy would you share with the
audience your game and Yvonne chat went
through the whole game beautifully
eloquently explaining all the details of
the position where the subtle yeah it
was all good it was all good yeah and
then I said well why did the opponent
resign and it necessarily went and I
said well that's really really nice
thank you very much but could you do it
one move at a time for the audience and
he did now this position is forced and
think about it for a second how would
you win it if you were white like what
moves would you make here you might
consider for example a move like f6 to
set up a breakthrough with the pawn
coming to e6 but that would actually not
work because of poor King king
no that's definitely not the right
method
so what move do you think is the right
move what do you think three King to D 3
so this makes a lot of sense because
what you're gonna do is you're gonna
come roaring around here but then comes
King to d5 and of course black for Oh
actually actually let me
I apologize let me first trade these
ponds takes takes and then King to d5
and so blacks ideas obviously he wants
to just grab both of these guys alright
yes young man never mind
are you saying that e6 you bet e6 okay
well I don't think I have much choice
here I'll take it yes and now f6 so this
is this is known as the breakthrough
pawn breakthrough so now in order to
stop the for the pawn from promoting
blacks King is dragged Vic is yes blacks
King has to move to King b6 okay so now
what should white do c4 you bet
so in this position essentially white
has passed pawns that are far and black
has passed pawns that are far away but
at all it's all a matter of timing so
for example 'if I've c5 check where we
can't capture the pawn King has to move
away King
check wait for a second exactly
and now you're threatening the queen
with check and you clean with check
check and light winds very very very
nice a example of the split pawns or you
could even come all the way back here
with the Queen and start grabbing all of
these pawns - all right so that so
Yvonne Chaka explaining the game to me
and when he finishes explaining the king
of pawn endgame he goes and every good
grandmaster would see that right away oh
thank you very much Roger very very very
nice insulted on my own show what can I
tell you so let me just pull up another
one well not in that case this one was a
nice game and a very instructional and a
very instructional one so it was the
first round gosh was it really that long
ago yet 1983 I was white and my opponent
was Gary Kasparov Gary had not yet won
the World Championship but he had
certainly made his mark in the world of
chess he was already the second highest
rated player in the world and we got to
this fairly even position be 593 he took
took and play King d6
and here we were any King upon endgame
and as they say this was the proverbial
move 40 the last move of time control
all right so I'm why
eight and essentially I'm juggling two
moves I'm I'm thinking about the move
King D for as well as about the movie
for it's clear that black has a queen
side majority and the outside I have the
King side majority
I wouldn't want black for example to be
able to play g5 and g4 in one move and
he kills my majority so I've got to
activate my majority and the question
for me was if I play king d4 and he
plays f5 and I play E for and he takes
and I take was that a good decision for
me would that be good decision or
conversely I could play E 4 F 4 E 4 f 4e
5 and try to get my majority going very
quickly in such positions it's really
terrible there aren't really any
wonderful principles to guide our
decision we simply have to calculate the
position on its individual merits so got
reactions who thinks King D 4 is a
really good move who would say efore was
pretty good move it's not okay so in
fact King D 4 is a real good move I
played efore d4 and my opponent Gary
really played perfectly to prove that
this position he has a forced win it's
like the move 40 force twin will come
back and I will look at King D 4 and why
I would have made a draw had I played
that mu
after the movie for Gary played the move
g6 g5 which is really a brilliant move
and I hadn't given that move a great
deal of attention for some reason when I
was oscillating between King d4 and e4
the move that had my attention the most
was F v g5 on the other hand threatens
to play g4 which would freeze my king
side and black would win very easily by
just creating a passed pawn over on the
Queen side f4 takes takes king here and
now I realized to my horror like my
pawns are frozen the moment i play for
example 'if i've my opponent's gonna
play king d5 so my pawns will remain
frozen then I go a4 a5 b4 force a passed
pawn and then go king e4 and round up my
pawns so I had to wait so we reached
this position and it's black to play
what should black play I should like to
what do you think black should do okay
b4 let's see why he didn't play b4 okay
if he had played before I think that is
it my plan was to play a four
yeah well I at the moment my king is
keeping his King out and it's sort of
like a tempo race so like one thing he
could do for example is try b3 King here
b2 King takes King here that looks kind
of interesting okay but you have to work
it out
King b3 King takes King here King takes
King here yeah let's say here let's say
here
yeah yeah six six seven seven
Queen Queen now it's more than likely
black is going to be able to pick up
this pawn on h2 and we're getting into a
queen ending but my chances of drawing
this are simply excellent you don't have
to play b3 right away you could play
other moves to just casually waiting for
the right moment so let's see how he did
it
he played h5 very good move h4 b for a
for f6 okay so basically he's given the
move to me i don't want the who i want
it to be his turn I if I move my king
then I am losing to King c4 and that's
very simple for him he's just going to
be able to push his pawn here and he'll
also gain the square d 4 for his King so
I had to play a 5 ok so now what blacks
winning strategy is he wants this
exact position but he wants it to be my
move
so black has to lose a turn okay so how
does black lose a turn he does it
through the method of triangulation how
many of you familiar with triangulation
very good all right
it took me a I worked very hard to
understand the idea of triangulation but
I think that this was a very nice
example of it King comes back I keep his
King in opposition he goes back I can't
go forward and keep his King in
opposition because I had I remain tied
to the pawn on b3 so I have to make a
turn I wait he waits
now he's established what we call
distant opposition after I play here he
plays here and he has exactly the same
position as he wanted and it's my turn I
ended up playing here and I resigned as
he's promoting his pawn with check oh
that one hurt that was a very very
hurtful one how about another really
good hurtful game oh I've had a lot of
fun and King and pawn endings now let's
see Leonid sham kovitch okay this was
this was a real disaster oh gosh oh gosh
this was this was a very very hard I was
white against a very very strong
Grandmaster from the Soviet Union at the
time his name was lianna champ kovitch
he eventually came to the United States
as a defector and when he was here he
played in US Championships and boy did
he win a lot of tournaments so I was 17
years old we were playing in Lone Pine
California and I had basically reached
this overwhelming position as white like
all of my pieces are better the pawn
structure is better for me
I'm completely winning and I get this
position now today I mean I don't even
know what I was thinking
today and without question I would just
take the bishop take a pause two pawns
up maybe I'm gonna go rook here or maybe
rook over and my king is coming up I've
got the better structure and my coupons
ahead and his pawns are all weak no that
would have been a good move
I played rook here and immediately went
into a King and pawn in game upon up
this is completely winning I mean I'm
just completely winning or this is
nothing to be said King can come Oh over
here pawn will come over once I put my
king up over here and move my pawn here
I'll get a pass D pawn and I win the
game very very easily mmm what's that
what is that as a move of course of
course of course he goes without saying
that in King and pawn n games one of the
things you very much ought to do and do
it very quickly is activate your King
that's a good principle I played f4
because I had a very clear idea in my
head I was going to go King F to e4 he
couldn't allow me to play e5
establishing a connected passed pawn he
would have to trade I'll trade with my
king I go d4 d5 put my king on d4 and
when very simply so so far so good now
for some strange reason I still can't
understand it today many years later
efore is just resigns that that just
wins the game on the spot III he goes
king c5
no no I start wondering have I blown it
I don't know did I blow it
I played King f3 he took took b7 b6 and
now I played king e - ok so my idea very
simply was that if he goes king D for
I'll go king D - he'll have to retreat
with this king I'll go king c3 and I'll
get the position I want by just pushing
my pawn and he can resign so he goes
King before so I go King D - he goes Kim
B 3 oops
what do I do now oh my gosh he I went
King he - he went king before notice he
didn't go king c3 had he gone king c3 I
would have played King III and I would
have activated my king this way yeah
that did not happen
he played King King King King King and
now the move he played was King before
okay so now I played King D - a king F -
and I'm hoping for king 2 C 3 so that I
can go king te 3 and got him he goes
came to be 300 boy what's going on what
did I do
I went King II won so my idea was that
if he goes King up I'll go King up and
then I'll follow him and eventually I'd
force him out of troubles he goes king
c3 and when I played King e2 he said
that's three time repetition
Oh oh no I made a draw from a completely
one position
I didn't realize had made a three move
repetition that's something else that in
Kingdom fun and games when you're trying
to be really clever and make a lot of
moves in win tempo sometimes three time
repetition could occur this was a
painful non victory oh boy oh boy oh boy
but just to try to reestablish my
reputation with yourselves
this one you're really going to love
okay
which kind of combines both so I'm good
I was black this was played in the Chess
Olympiad of 1994 and lets me see which
country was my I think my opponent was
an international master from Peru
so after lots and lots of we get to a
position like this okay
hello greetings okay so King takes a
three was my opponent's last move and
it's black to play okay now here I was
very happy with my position as I think
you can understand I have some very
interesting choices and a two in
particular have got my attention the
first choice I have is to play rook h5
my opponent would likely play King
before and I could play rook takes h2
when I'm a pawn up in a rook ending but
let me just let me just a rate just a
second do something here notation
training that's what I mean
so rook here so this was let us say one
of my main variations my main analysis
variation was that I seemed they're
going well
black really has good counterplay
because I was afraid that if I went h5
King here h4 takes foresight this looks
really good until you see check there's
like I hate that so I wouldn't be able
to play h5 I probably have to bring my
rook to bring my rook behind the pawn
and let's face it White has good counter
play good counter chances of making a
draw with good play ii thought that went
through my mind was what about check and
going into this King and pawn endgame
well as you're just seeing with my game
with Garry Kasparov you got to be a
little bit worried when your opponent
has a passed pawn on the Queen side
because he may use it as a decoy to
bring his King all the way and gobble
your pawns on the Kings side so the
first point was is this endgame
favorable for me or for my opponent
whereas maybe I should go into that rook
ending and just play a pawn ahead so I
had to look very deeply into this
position because I wasn't sure whether I
was winning losing or drawing first
impressions who thinks that White's
winning who thinks at White's drawing
you think it's at blacks winning okay
well the only reason I thought I was
even in there with a chance was because
I had this pawn on g4 which was
basically keeping these three guys
frozen I made the decision to go into
the King pond end game and all my
teammate who are watching the game
immediately got out and they went out
the playing halter to argue amongst
themselves like you know did I why
didn't ya sir just go and take the pond
okay so the next few moves were pretty
straightforward and we could reach here
okay so now I have ideas like I can move
my pawn up here to e5 I can move my pawn
to f5 and my opponent could be moving
back and forth or back and forth like
this and eventually I'm going to have to
move my pawns and I'm gonna have to make
a breakthrough
just like even shot did against Joe Bova
but I have to do it in the right way so
that the tempo is in my favor when I
make the breakthrough
I played 'if I've okay my opponent
played king d3 and I played f5 keeping
my opponent's king away from the e4
square you played King c3 so what's
going on in my head is I'm thinking that
I've got to play h4 f 4e 4 huh an h4 all
in the right move order okay now he can
no longer play King here to d3 because
that would allow king before and then
he'd simply lose the C pawn so to
maintain his C pawn he's going to be
moving back and forth between b3 and c3
and while he's over in that
that direction I'm gonna play E for f4
III but I got to make sure his Kings
over there
so what move did I make okay h5 is one
move and then he's going to go King b3
and then what can I do
so if I go h5 and he goes King b3 what
could I do if I go F 4 he'll go King c3
and I have to be careful now that I'm
not losing because he's going to go King
so I have to go efore he would take
mm-hmm
does this look like Evon Chuck's game
where remember he had an F on and a
thief on rut rope so what I did was in
this position oops
just a second I played efore whew okay
so my idea was that he couldn't drop
back with his King B cos does it sorta
let me just see let me just make sure
this yeah evil so h5 I think that move
was just wrong okay so II for King b3 h6
King c3 h5 king d 3f
or woo
so this is the breakthrough so now he
has to take here take here so now he
cannot stop me from playing g3 takes h3
and I can go all the way up the board or
even to recapture okay but this is the
position I have seen before I went in to
the King and pawn ending whoa
but I was still not sure that this is
winning for me why because he goes f5 so
now I have to be careful g3 does not win
the game for example
g3 --tags --tags f6 now he's threatening
to promote with check right so I've got
to bring my King back he'll check me
whew I can't take the pawn because then
his F pawn goes and he goes like this
and now he's threatening to check and
white makes a queen oh so back back to
this position after f5 I had to return
with my King King to d6 okay
white cannot play f6 I'll go King here
c5 King takes sorry let me put this on
the board
white cannot play f6 because I'll go
King here I'll wipe out this pawn and
I'll be back in time to stop this pawn
from making a cream so we go back to
this position my opponent plays King
before okay now let's see again what
about g3 well let's say he takes takes
and gives me a check whew where do I
move my king yes and then King e5 that's
a good move c6 capture this fun oops
it can't do that c6
so c6g to c7 Queen oops
Queen Queen and I can't secure whites
Queen white King doesn't go on to the C
file of course that's a bad square but
it just makes its way to whites Queen
and I should be happy to make a draw
right okay so I had seen this position
in my mind and I didn't play g3 g3 would
not win the game but which move did I
play and then King e5 correct
kingi five so here's the point
c5 okay got a wipe this guy out and then
let's say he goes King here yes and he
goes King here
then he goes King here in g3 then he
goes c6 check yeah I blew it
oh no hate that so King here King here
g3 correct takes take back push push
put lip sorry push push hey drag read
right yes so we're here put pardon me
takes correct
now King b7o very nice after king b7 he
walks in to check let's go back so we're
back to this position before
instead of that he plays
efore Eve well okay then I so a moment
ago we're kind of here and essentially
what he wants to do is to be able to
advance his pawn with the tempo and what
my move kingi five does is it gets out
of the tempo events and it puts me in
the square of the pawn so after Eve oh
pardon me after E for defending the pawn
on d5 then I'd you can just go ahead and
make a queen and his pawns are a long
way from promotion a long long long way
from promotion yeah one of the most
difficult this so this this ending by
the way had all of those flavors right
it had the the pawns kind of split the
outside pass pawn the majority the pawn
breakthroughs you know finagling your
opponent's king into a diagonal so that
I could give a check when I promote it
and I think that one of the hardest and
favorite positions so I must have had
cruel teachers at least Jeffery parson
took a great interest in making me
struggle so the idea of course was he
gave me this position he said white to
move and win and then I you know of
course very happily
well what I gotta do is come over here
and just take all of these pawns and win
so I would play king c5 and he would
play king c7 and pretty soon I would
just get to a position that we would
make a draw and as I you know what am I
doing wrong
actually I think in certain occasions
I'm not quite sure how I managed I think
I even managed to lose the position I
mean it wasn't just good enough that he
would give me a physician and say white
to move and win I did I turn it into a
loss I was pretty I was pretty good very
proud of myself so of course I never
solved this problem making a long story
short right and when he did have mercy
on me and he showed me the solution it
really like wow it just blew me away and
you all know the solution right yeah the
middle fun it correct push the middle
pont g v g6 and I just love this
breakthrough this one I really did get
right away this was really cute okay
that one I thought was really charming
this one didn't come quite so readily
for some reason I had a great idea and
the powers of the King and it really
took me quite some time to realize that
black skin is too slow
it seemed like the black king would just
just in instantly be at the gate to
defend the pond from promotion and this
one didn't come readily but these pawn
breakthroughs are really really some of
the most charming of key and Ponta
endgame when you try to study King and
pawn n games the way I personally found
King and pawn end games to be both far
too challenging and at times far too
boring
like I gotta weigh the scales of like
being bored to death and then you know
just not being able to solve and find
the answers so I set up a little imagery
with myself and what I tried to do was
take out a chess clock and give myself
ten minutes to solve the position and to
imagine I was playing for the US
Championship that the outcome of the
game decided the u.s. championship and
if I could figure out the the the
problem and get it right
I'd become the US Champion so trying to
put myself under you know a tournament
stressful condition was the way I tried
to study King and pawn in games I didn't
always get it right
but I can tell you there's some really
really fascinating and complex materials
on King upon iing games again I would
say that the most important principles
of the King upon a game to realize is
who's got the most active King like a
lot of Kampong game and game's boils
down to that second one who has the more
important past pawn you know often see
those King and pawn in games with the
past pawns for both players but one one
guy one of the ponds is more important
than the other and the third principle
is that there really isn't any principle
other than you're gonna have to
calculate each and every position it's
unique and well those are the principles
of King and fun hanging questions
questions questions and I don't have any
of you played a king of pawn endgame in
your tournament careers they're not very
common okay they're not very common
normally speaking a lot of them may not
be challenging in other words you may
already have been winning horribly like
I was winning with sham Kovich and just
transposed into an easily winning king
upon endgame in
you blew it or you just simply won it or
you are able to draw it but these King
and pawning games are really really
worth studying it's hard at times to
bring yourself up to the task but make
an effort make an effort
may may help you win an important
tournament game